kamala there's something different
in your genes are they levi's like
like a mutation
let's
people are gonna have opinions about
this this is a pretty big retcon bro the
90s cartoon more of the 90s cartoon to
the mcu please more of that i love the
music i love using the music that's what
they got a sound board every time we
hear the word mutant during the
character you know kevin feige's back
they're like please play the music
glitter hey it works it works for me i
love it
is that not normal
what
what just happened
oh
oh wait did she
turn into her or
no i don't know
[Music]
no okay so that's not kamala she
wouldn't look around the room like yeah
what is
[Music]
that
this
i mean that is much better than i
expected
that is so cool it looks like they
swapped places but they didn't meet i
think that's really cool the way they
did it i mean what an what an
interesting way to in the series i i
i'm so pleasantly surprised by this i
thought i was gonna be like okay she's
recruiting her now this is like this
poses so many more questions this way
hell yeah man of mine
places what is their connection i assume
it'll be answered in the marvel where
the hell did she go
this series overall i i think they stuck
the landing but leaves us with so many
questions
as always welcome back to new rock stars
miss marvel did it they finally said the
thing yeah and bigen right no not but
they didn't begin captain marvel's cameo
well very interesting but i'm not
referring to that either yes the big m
word mutation yup that's it retcon alert
kamala khan in the mcu is a mutant the
first character in the 616 mcu to be
identified as such but when it comes to
that post-credits scene
what is going on
this is inside marvel new rockstar's
official after show for ms marvel we're
breaking down the finale today i'm eric
voss my easter egg breakdown of this
episode is gonna come tomorrow but right
now discussing this episode's many
questions with me is empty
[Music]
yes
but my god dude i'm so freaking excited
to see more mutant integration into the
mcu it's about damn time let's go yeah
uh absolutely i mean i think they should
have said mutant like years ago but now
that they finally have i think it's i
think it's great this just means many
more great things are ahead but yeah uh
many of us are having some whiplash like
wait what does this mean for the
inhumans what does this mean for kamala
khan what does this mean for the marvels
what does this mean for mutant kind in
general we're going to talk about all
that this episode but let's recap
exactly what happened the episode begins
with kamala confessing to her family
that she is the light girl the night
lights but of course they already knew i
i like this uh in the comics i believe
it goes down the same way like the
family is already aware of it i think
that's wonderful
moniba gives kamala her new suit that uh
incorporates the various elements from
the different parts of her community i
thought it was a sweet moment it's in
the milk toffees box that i thought was
really nice like everything great from
this family just comes from
sucks
isn't that sweet um i i makes me wonder
like wait did uh muniba know that the
blue part of the uh
the
textile comes from walid and she
understands the significance of the red
dagger sash
no time
it's just here
she's just a really good designer um so
bruno and camaron are fleeing the dodc
and on this subway at the beginning
camaron's like holding his stomach and
we're like wait what's going on did he
get shot in the stomach or something
like that did bruto stab him what's
going on is he pregnant just kidding
[Laughter]
um but we find out that uh he had like
this this energy that was given to him
by najma it's causing him to feel like
he's being crumbled from the inside
which is just like such a horrifying
thing
for him to describe it's so terrifying
uh like
leaves us with so many questions about
what the nor light is and
like but at least i like that it wasn't
just something that was immediate power
up it was more of a burden and a curse
on him that uh that he needed to be able
to understand before he could just
immediately start blowing stuff up with
without consequence so they go first to
the mosque where that chic gives them
the classic mcu disguise of ball caps i
love that like here perfect you're good
to go
they have half of a disguise just in the
sunglasses they're good to go
the kids all meet at the school uh where
they get barricaded in by agent d versus
dodc forces and all the kids are there
we got kamala we got bruno and cameron
and they're joined by nakia zoe and amir
zoe has this line i'm like i was just
the theater they have the best lighting
like this is just what kind of theater
stage lights is the best light for like
uh for tick tock i mean those are pretty
they must have a pretty well calibrated
stage lighting to have it be perfectly
balanced because i mean if i if i'm
thinking
tick tock i'm thinking of a ring light
that's nice up and close look this is
just youtuber talk right now i'm
thinking like the stage lights i had in
my high school theater were had to be
like rented and brought in and strung up
on tree lights and they were not there
for our rehearsals we only had them
rented for like 48 hours of the show and
they always like there's some kid on the
light board like i don't know what i'm
doing
just like like intimidating sometimes
yeah
they spilled my o.j on it
there's a fire
the drama teacher is just like matt what
are you doing
he's like i don't know
i'm just trying to get tech hours so i
can get my ib diploma
ah
this was me for one of the productions
i i
i'm speaking favorably so many plays yep
um
anyway they they come up with this real
scrappy plan of wearing matching hoodies
and using fire extinguishers using
really fun a completely unnecessary
skeleton holding a knife uh that pops a
balloon
that causes chemistry lap but i get like
the chemistry lab foam and like a delay
in it so that it would like you know pop
or whatever but could you just like put
it on like a
pull string or something like that or a
tripwire do they cause a string or you
just like pour it in there and run like
the fact that they had to have skeleton
popped it's more fun to see they had a
lot of home alone time in that school
right
there was a lot of extra steps we'll
just say that
but hey it was fun to watch uh the
regular kids get caught komron and
kamala are are stuck inside but they're
fighting using their nor light and
cameron realizes that his mother died
and turns violent oh we got a little
thing i don't want to overlook this
moment with nakia and zoe and zoe says
well just you know you could tell people
on your own time
and uh we don't go further than that but
i like that i i wish that they just came
out and said what her uh romantic
affections are for
because in the comics they have like
zoey totally crushes on nokia
um but like here they just kind of like
again just kind of like hinted at it but
like who knows we're gonna get a second
season of miss marvel like now is the
time to just say like hey can i get your
digits girl like right go ahead and have
her hit on her openly what's wrong with
that
what is wrong with that we need to just
like show people for who they are rather
than have them like dance around it
right i mean i feel like it's coming in
time i like i i do like because like
they don't really know each other that
much so like it would be like i feel
like it i want to see them grow as
friends first before they like go into a
relationship but like fair enough i do
don't know when we're gonna see that
though not exactly i do wish that there
was something there because like i like
that little hint but like it's not
enough because i want to see more yeah
uh but cameron realizes his mother died
he turns violent uh kamala has to try to
restrain him and then outside deever's
agents are firing on them kamala in big
and she even says the word like willing
herself to embiggen and i love that she
uses the word and bigoted but then she
like stretches her body out i was hoping
she'd go full ant-man here i was hoping
like a nice like 25 foot tall kamala
that's what i wanted instead it was just
kind of this weird thing where like iman
valadi's body was just kind of stretched
out by like an extra foot on each of her
limbs uh and we didn't really get to see
it uh that much like we saw a shot of
her jumping we saw a shot of her
reflected in the car window and then we
had her showed for like maybe two
seconds at a time and then we cut away
we never got this big hero moment of her
actually stretching out like all we
really saw was what we had seen before
which are like her hands grabbing things
which are all things that like we saw in
trailer footage we saw elsewhere like
ah it's fine it's fine like it didn't
blow my mind personally i'm glad that
they went there um i just hope that they
do more of it it's i i felt like the
strain of the vfx budget i'll say that
yeah at times during these disney plus
shows you can definitely see
like all right oh i thought i was
watching a marvel movie but like this is
definitely still a tv show like they do
have their restraints there i mean i
would have preferred had you spent like
maybe half of the amount of money they
spent on uh showing cameron's weird
terror formation and just like if you
could just shift all that budget into
more embiggening uh shots a little bit
more fun
but that's i'm not really sure exactly
what he's doing it seems like just kind
of like chaotic explosion he's just mad
did it seem like he was terraforming the
earth with with nor light to turn it to
the north dimension or was it just like
i don't know what i'm doing
like the light board guy
i just feel like his powers are just
going out of control personally and like
yeah his like it's this life energy
that's in him was just growing out of
him like vines and so it's just like all
right we're just growing from the source
of this like this tree if you will like
this this human living being and it's
like spreading out and so yeah i like
that kamala encased them both in this
dome
which reminded me of the territory
cocoon in a lot of right right um and
like i like how within that cocoon you
see like his teal and gold covered more
fading away and her purple color kind of
overtaking it um what i want to know is
she uses her bigger hand to just punch a
hole in the concrete and he's like okay
bye i'm like wait did he assume you
punch a hole into the sewer does he know
how to navigate the sewers in jersey
city to get to the shoreline
does he know where he's going did he
punch a hole like how deep did that hole
go where did the earth go
i mean you know at the very least tiamat
on the other side of the earth felt a
little pinched like what
what's going on logical pinch like what
is going on why is no one talking about
me i'm here i'm here we got we went to
pakistan we went we weren't that far we
were maybe a thousand miles away from me
right we could the flight might have
gone over me we could have had kamala
peek out the window and see a giant me
just kind of floating in the indian
ocean no
but no
i don't think the flight path would go
over uh that way um right anyway i would
i would have loved to see a tiamat like
graffiti somewhere like pakistan or
something like it would have been great
or just a a booth at avenger con of
people talking about this that would be
amazing a ski resort on tiamont
get your get your tickets here uh so um
the community surrounds kamala and
cleary calls off diver yusuf tells
kamala that in urdu kamal means
wonderful or marvel making her their
little miss marvel uh and then a week
later bruno the guy is headed to caltech
he tells kamala that he studied her gene
profile and realized that there was
something different about her genes
compared to her family and uses the word
mutation we all lose our minds as we
hear the 90s x-men theme but kamala
shrugs it off with just another label
good luck kamala because people on
twitter have opinions about this
and then we move on to a post-credit
scene where kamala's bengal glows a new
color and her body suddenly scrambles
into this ribbon and it makes her it
seems like at first transform into
captain marvel captain marvel was
wearing an altered version of her suit
and carol says oh no no and runs out of
the room and the credits confirmed that
ms marvel will return in the marvels
the end of the season
a bit of applause i think overall i
really really like this show yeah it uh
it lost me a little bit in some moments
but overall this ending just throws a
lot at us
and uh i'm happy that we went on this
journey i liked it yeah i liked it
better i think than most of the uh
marvel disney plush shows does not does
not overtake loki for me or want to
visit me
number one number two those are peak i
love them i really love those but no
this was really great like it's it's a
super nice like wholesome show about
family like it's all about family and um
i just really enjoyed meeting like
kamala's friends and family and then
kamala herself it's just like that
corner of the universe like feels like
i feel like home a little bit because
like this is like one of the first
families that are together in the mcu
are not broken i don't know this is like
we're seeing a real hero family so like
i'm going to miss them i'm going to miss
like my little thanksgiving bob's dad's
me or my big brother of the year it's
gonna be gonna miss them agreed this was
so wholesome and uh and i hope we get to
revisit this community at some point um
because it was delightful just to
explore jersey city uh and the members
of uh of kamala's community so many
interesting characters it really did
feel like a small town vibe and that's
how you know you have a good show is
when you feel like you're actually
living in a neighborhood for six weeks
or however long it is now we're going to
talk about kamala's mutant retcon this
episode but we're going to start with
what just happened in this scene with
captain marvel because yeah i think that
in some ways is more confusing and more
interesting as we look ahead um but be
sure to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com so you don't miss out
on your chance to grab our ms marvel
latest obsession shirt cosmic daydream
they're almost gone along with the
ability to unlock a custom shout out to
appear right here on inside marvel so
frank says alp you are the beauty in my
pieces thank you my superhero that's so
sweet frank that's so nice to say alp
you're a lucky person jessica says we
love miss marvel the history and
authenticity agreed jessica we're with
you and then caitlyn asks what if the
blue arm with a bengal is actually
atlantean maybe namor has the other
bangle caitlyn i like where your mind is
going uh that'd be very interesting um
yeah especially since it seems like a
lot of atlanteans in the mcu are going
to be going to be blue colored they
would just like
who
i guess the question is like does it
make more sense for the ten rings to be
connected to atlantis or to the cree i
can make arguments for either to be
honest with you yeah um there's so much
we don't know about the atlanteans but i
uh we'll have to revisit that theory
after black panther what kind of forever
stuff comes out no for sure like i i've
i've definitely ever since we saw those
pictures of atuma i was like oh we got
another blue person that's not greed so
uh yeah that's definitely a possibility
for sure good thinking caitlyn good
thing caitlyn all right mt what's our
first question after the miss marvel
finale all right homie first question of
the day is did kamala khan transform
into carol denver's or did they just
swap places
yeah uh so kamala appearing to transform
into carol danvers i think was at least
on the surface done to pay homage to the
comics when kamala first leaves that
terrigen cocoon her wish fulfillment
causes her to initially take the form of
carol danvers and it seems like they
even paid tribute to that with carol's
new look like rather than the red
gauntlet length gloves her forearms are
bare and she wears like these darker
fingerless gloves which looks more like
the kamala khan version of carol danvers
in the comment in the comics who like
just looks like she's growing out of her
suit like she's just like awkwardly
fitting these clothes that just like
don't really fit her that well and it's
meant to be kind of like an awkward
intermediary step to a final form um but
i i think we should look more at carol's
specific captain marvel suit design here
because unlike other uh it looks unlike
any of her past ones it's actually
closest to her look from the end of the
2019 captain marvel which is set back in
the 90s but when carol returned in that
post-credits scene which is right after
the snap in the modern era she
definitely had a new suit with more gold
trimming on it the end game opening
sequence uh also was different than the
five years later when she returned uh
via holochat with the shorter haircut
she had like a new look that was a look
she had during the final battle of
endgame uh all of these were very
different suits than this one uh and
those they were like blue on top and
then red around the midsection around
the legs but now it's more like just a
bit of red at top and mostly blue like
even blue boots uh a completely new look
for carol danvers it's just interesting
so i think kamala did not turn into uh
uh uh carol danvers uh like a
doppelganger of carol danvers uh if so i
don't think she'd be if it was still
kamala's mind i don't think she'd be as
concerned with the posters around the
room yeah um because that's her posters
i think she would have we would have got
a shot of her looking in the mirror at
her new form and being like oh my god
what happened to me um
like i don't think uh she'd be as
confused about her surroundings um i
think really what happened is kamala and
carol swapped places
um now i don't have a good explanation
for why i'm gonna do my best uh i think
this is actually carol danvers here in
this jersey city bedroom um that's why
she's not like surprised by her body
she's just kind of surprised by her
surroundings she's weirded out that
she's suddenly in a kid's bedroom a kid
that worships her and has posters of her
i think that freaks her out
um that was probably her first
experience with a super fan
that's right she's like someone actually
knows and cares who i am i'm barely here
like why do they have all these pictures
of me i can't handle this
uh
and uh and before this we started
rolling mt you pointed out and i think
it may be right that this scene even
totally feels a little different this
might have been shot by the director of
the marvel's i believe it's nia acosta
like it just kind of feels like a
completely different energy
yeah it just it felt like it was filmed
differently i don't know how to explain
it like different cameras like it just
had a whole different vibe like sort of
how like um when we had that a civil war
post credit scene at the end of um
ant-man i believe where um like with um
when bucky had his thing in the uh
when bucky had his arm in that thing and
like they were talking about seeing
ant-man i just felt like it was just
filmed differently so like i don't know
that maybe that's just me i mean we see
this a lot um like i believe in phase
three a lot of directors for the next
film would direct the post-credits scene
right the movie that came before um so
and you know there was that vibe for the
wanted mission post credit scene where
people were saying like the camera
movement reminding us of the sam raimi
camera movement i don't know if sam
raimi actually shot it i honestly
wouldn't be surprised if a second unit
directing team did it but uh it seems
like what they're going for is the vibe
of where we're next going to see right
and to me what was most different about
this was the production design of the
way this transference happened like it
did not it wasn't like a glow of light
the way it often is in the mcu like
that's that's my gripe with the
production design is like oh just
another glow of light oh this one's a
different color what does this color
mean like like i'm getting a little
tired of that i want to see something
different happen uh like with spiderman
no way home they use like sparkle
portals which made sense with like the
doctor strangeness of it but like
there's so many other ways to show how
universes are collide and how
teleportation happens other than just
like the glow of a portal uh and so this
one looked like
a weird almost like
uh teleportation to where her body was
twisted in the ribbon right
and it just looked really cool like it
was like this mysterious thing that had
me asking so many more questions rather
than making assumptions and i think
that's what you want to do when you
when you introduce new things for sure
so let's ask why they swap places and
how this happened if that is the
assumption if that is the correct
assumption well the episode indicated to
us that kamala in the mcu and the 616
mcu is considered a mutant the nor light
was inherited from a great grandmother
her great-grandmother aisha clandestine
from another dimension but the reason
the bangle activated her apparently was
that kamala had a genetic anomaly the
mutant gene which unlike other genetic
features like being an inhuman
uh the the x gene the mutant gene
springs up randomly in certain
individuals it's considered a dormant
thing that's just kind of randomly
spread throughout the population and
certain things can activate it most of
the time it's just puberty the natural
uh uh maturation cycle uh but sometimes
it's like other things that can activate
it and it seems like in this case the
bangle might have activated it um but
that bengal itself remains a mystery its
origins are definitely connected to the
tin rings and
as of now i still believe it is more
connected to cree tech
especially since carol danvers now is
connected to it i think this is right um
it might even be something empowered or
linked to the space stone and i think
that is the other part of this equation
because we have to remember that carol
danvers cosmic radiation came from the
space stone came from the tesseract and
the space stone specifically allows for
manipulation of space the opening of
wormholes this the movement at the speed
of light and teleportation right and we
know that the bengal for its part can
open rifts through space time right i
think
a lot of people are asking if this is
the cree uh the captain marvel mega
bands which open uh open gates to the
the negative zone i don't know if
they're ever going to call it that but i
think it's helpful to at least look at
it as a uh as an analog to that right
from the comics um and the mega bands
are something that is linked to the
creased supreme intelligence it allows
uh access to the uh
to the negative zone and i think it's
interesting to remember that every time
not every time but often when characters
teleport in the marvel comics they're
not just like moving from place to place
they're actually
traveling through some other realm or
dimension like even nightcrawler when
nightcrawler teleports he's actually
going through another dimension right
to go from point to point within our
dimension uh and that may be what this
technology is it may allow through
teleportation
by uh by crossing through some other
dimension that other dimension might be
the negative zone i think that's
a new realm that i'm very excited to see
uh especially as we go more into this
cosmic direction with the cree and the
fantastic four um i hope dr doom is
coming into the mcu soon and then
they'll start to codify these terms a
bit more that's just where my head is at
right now of course it's gonna explain
further in the marvels but it seems like
kamala's cree tech is what created some
kind of spatial entanglement through
this cree cosmic-powered captain marvel
uh and that link created a this
humorously chaotic handcuff gag i think
that's what i think they're setting up
what i think is gonna be a really fun
thing in the marvels where these two are
linked through this tech and they're
constantly chaotically switching places
putting kamala in a place that she does
not want to be avoiding carol in a place
where she does not want to be at any
given moment uh and um
i at the end of the day i still think
the ten rings are summoning the kree to
earth i think that they're going to stay
the 10 rings or cree tech as well and
that the cree will be chasing down the
other bangle now the question is is
where is the other bangle right i could
say it's with dane whitman uh that's
among the collections of his uncle
nathan in in the uk maybe it's in a
museum somewhere maybe it's with the
cree currently maybe captain marvel has
the other one but she's not wearing the
other bangle when she zips into the the
jersey city bedroom there um so
it wouldn't be just because she's
wearing the other bangle that's why they
swap places um i just think like
you know i could be wrong if they are
turning kamala into carol i just think
it'd be weird to have the central gag of
the marvels be hey let's take him on
valani off screen for as much as movie
as possible so that brie larson get
double screen time i don't think that's
the case i think they're swapping places
i guess the question is if carol is now
here in jersey city where did kamala go
right what do you think empty i i
honestly think that you know there's a
good chance that carol danvers was
handling the the second bangle and like
she picked it up and then there's a
weird energetic reaction between her
own um energetic singularities versus
kamalas and so that's why she's looking
at her hand like yo what's going on and
like they just switch swap spots and
kamala probably went to that second
bengal it's like all right uh carol had
it she touched it we just did a weird
switcheroo just like uh the original
captain marvel and rick jones like with
the mega bands like that was their whole
thing for a while the whole uh um like
little gimmick i wouldn't say gimmick
but like the whole special thing is that
they would switch places sometimes and
like switch
positions in like space so i really love
that they're going for this
angle like a similar type of angle for
the marbles uh because like i do like
like you said like i do like this i like
a good handcuff situation it's like now
i'm handcuffed with a super fan who
loves me and this is gonna be really
awkward and like i also have to team up
with this little girl who resents me for
leaving her and like it's gonna be a
really fun time
like i really love it it's gonna be fun
i uh yeah i like that like unlike other
uh post-credit stingers that just kind
of like introduce characters to each
other and give us a hint at production
design this actually gives us a sense of
the plot of the marvels which right i i
really really appreciate like it gives a
sense of what their actual relationship
is and the the comedic tone of this
movie which is not what i expected at
all um i like that they did something
really different with the the way that
teleportation looks i think that's fun
and i and i hope the mcu does more of
that like gives us different makes
different design choices for how
characters power sets work uh and how
they are awkward and uncomfortable and
burdensome uh that's what's most fun
about it if anything i would have loved
like more of a goofy sound effect with
that like
no don't listen to me that would have
been
i would love but
[Music]
um yeah i think uh uh you brought up a
notch awesome theory there empty that
maybe uh carol was trying to hunt down
or track down like she was in some kind
of like indiana jones moment where she's
tracking down or trying to steal or
heist the other one from some cree deep
storage uh like i hope that kamala now
wakes up and finds herself
on some like i don't know some cree uh
space station somewhere or some cree
deep vault in holla and she's just like
completely thrown
the fact that she would be holding the
other one that would mean like carol is
like really stuck there but carol of
course can just like you know use her
she can travel around pretty quickly she
was able to save tony stark within like
an hour it seemed like so she can blast
back to holla uh and then but like she's
gonna be in the middle of some crisis
which i just i just love that idea right
we don't need to go through these steps
of the characters meeting each other uh
kamala already has this weird parasocial
relationship with carol it
we get to explore like this in a in a
very interesting way um
i think what i have more questions about
are like look i don't have a problem
with uh with milo being a mutant uh you
know i'm not too sacred about that it
just seems like there are a lot of
things she is on this show like she's
also a clandestine like she's also got
cree tech like the fact that her i'm not
exactly sure where her powers come from
is it's obviously not all from the
mutant gene uh because it must also come
from the bengal um a lot of people were
asking did she need the bengal at all i
think to be this version of the
character she did
um but it's just like it leaves us a
little fuzzy on what exactly her power
set is right i i think that like i mean
me personally i think that the bengals
brought out her inner power that she
always had
um but like it's gonna take like the x
gene or even the pterogen mist to
activate a specific mutation within her
blood and like again like you know they
did play the x-men music and like you
know it's very much implied that she is
an x-men type of mutant but like he said
mutation and like mutation is mutation
and and professor xavier is the like
master of all mutations and i feel like
that also includes the inhuman mutations
like i don't think that kamala
um being an inhuman is completely out of
the running quite yet i think that now
that uh
disney owns the rights to the fox x-men
i think that now they have the
opportunity to marry the concept of
inhumans with the x-men it's like hey
the humans are cousins to the x-men
because the cree came down they saw some
really interesting x genes in our blood
that um like promised that we were
capable of more and they probably just
locked down that x gene specifically
until there was a target missed um
uh what's it called trigger for it to
come in so like i feel like
uh the cree saw the x gene and they were
like all right let's just uh let's make
this our own let's make this our own
little uh fun thing and like we're gonna
find out in the marbles and moving
forward that like it's all the same
thing it's just another label that's i
feel like that's the significance of
that line it's like inhumans mutants
tomato tomato we all have superpowers
who cares um so i feel like that's
what's coming yeah i think um that's an
interesting uh interpretation mt i think
the uh the just another label line was
uh just a little too cute by half
because we don't really have a context
like if it is just another label
they then why say mutation include the
x-men music right like it seems like
marvel wants us to think of x-men in
that moment they want us to think of
mutants they want us to get hyped and
excited that more mutants are coming
right like i don't think uh this erases
inhumans existing in the mcu at least i
hope not like we saw black bolt and
multiverse of madness and i hope that
there is in humans in black bolt in 616
as well i'm gonna be disappointed if
there isn't um but uh i think in this
moment you just have to be careful like
explaining
what this means i hope we get those
answers at like comic con and d23 um but
um i think this is like an example of uh
marvel saying hey don't worry about the
label but if you're telling us don't
worry about the label don't say the word
mutation because you know what fans are
gonna do when you say the word mutant or
mutation um let's actually talk about
this more uh because i think that is
like the deeper question a lot of fans
are debating about but first we have
some people we want to thank for helping
us make this episode starting with our
friends at brooklyn and thank you to
brooklyn for sponsoring this episode of
inside marvel summer is officially upon
us and temperatures are rising luckily
for us brooklyn is here to help you keep
you cool and living in comfort at home
and on the go with their best-selling
bedding loungewear towels and more
brooklyn gives its customers hotel level
home essentials they offer everything
from snuggly sheets to cozy towels and
robes loungewear accessories and much
more by working directly with the
suppliers brooklyn cuts out the luxury
markups and passes those savings back to
their customers so you can get their
incredible products at a reasonable cost
in brooklyn and launches new products
colors and patterns all the time for
their sheets towels and robes they even
have some limited edition collections
that sell out fast make your entire bed
feel like the cool side of the pillow
with brooklyn and signature crisp
breathable classic percale sheets and
replace your heavy winter bedding with
their lightweight comforters for the
ultimate breezy light as the cloud feel
the smooth long-stable cotton will keep
you feeling cool all night and if you're
not sure where to start you can shop
with ease thanks to brooklyn's online
quiz whether you're looking for the
perfect set of cooling sheets
lightweight towels or breathable
loungewear their quiz is the best place
to find a curated list of high quality
products perfectly suited to your unique
preferences so head on over to brooklyn
today to keep you cool at home and on
the go all summer long go to
brooklyn.com and use the promo code
inside marvel to get 20 off your
purchase of 100 or more and free
shipping that's b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n
dot com and enter the promo code inside
marvel for 20 off and free shipping we
also thank helix sleep for sponsoring
this episode of inside marvel i sleep on
a helix mattress and it's just what i
need after a night of staying up late to
watch that ms marvel finale as soon as
it drops helix sleep is a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect matches for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for somebody else with helix you are
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way that you sleep
everybody is unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and fur mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot matches is great for spinal
alignment to prevent that morning ache
and pain and even a helix plus mattress
for plus size sleepers helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq in wired magazine
helix has been recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep just go to helix
sleep.com inside marvel take their two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life felix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com inside
marvel and thank you to raycon for
sponsoring this episode when i'm not
dissecting content down to every single
frame in hidden detail i like to listen
to podcasts and i love listening to
those podcasts on raycon's raycon's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever with optimized gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit their earbuds
are super comfortable and fit better
than homemade hulk costume your mom made
you last minute a costume that you
should say thank you to her for because
she spent a lot of time on it raycon's
offer three sound profiles to match what
you're listening to plus noise isolation
and awareness mode so that you can
choose to be immersed in sound or be
able to hear your surroundings when you
need to i really like using them around
the house like when i'm making dinner or
doing chores they're super secure and
they sound great raycons give you eight
hours of play time and a 32-hour battery
life you can even do wireless charging
with raycons you get the same quality
audio as other premium audio brands but
at half the price it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds have over 49
thousand five star reviews go to buy
raycon dot com inside marvel today to
get 15 off your raikon order that's by
raycon.com inside marvel to score 15 off
by recon dot com inside marvel all right
eric is kamala khan a mutant and what
does this mean for mutants and in humans
in the mcu my brother yeah i think the
implication of this exchange is that the
mcu is deciding to make kamala khan a
mutant in the 616 reality not an inhuman
like she is in the comics and yes this
is a retcon kamala khan is an inhuman in
the comics uh she was enveloped by
terrigen mist she entered a terrigen uh
cocoon there was all this missed a
result of a terrorist bomb that was
detonated by black belt when he was
fighting thanos like and i will say uh
this show
seemed to be terrigenophobic they worked
so hard to not say terrigen and not say
inhuman like they were like afraid to go
down that path and i think that was
weird at the end of the day like it
would have been simpler and i think they
were afraid of like well people aren't
gonna get the cocoon they're not gonna
get the mist i'm like i think they're
gonna get that more than what you did
ultimately because they they threw like
everything against the wall like from
alien tech that they never explained to
a clandestine dimension that they barely
explained to now the most uh
associated trigger word
among marvel fans
um now i think uh it's it's gonna
frustrate quite a few comics readers who
are really attached to the idea of
kamala being in inhuman uh let's remind
ourselves exactly of what the inhumans
comics history were um the inhumans like
many things marvel comics originated
during like the stanley jack kirby era
and the 60s comics um
but the uh
coming out of that decade
the inhumans were not like hugely
popular i think they were known like a
silver surfer was identified as an
inhuman slash mutant um but it's like
they were just like another one of these
uh things in the marvel world uh and
they were around in the 60s or the 70s
they were kind of back burnered in the
80s and 90s but there was like a really
good like uh i have not read it but it
did win some awards uh an inhuman uh
comic run at the end of the 90s and then
they came back in the next decade uh
with like black bolt being part of the
the illuminati and then in the decade
that followed i think this is when they
really got the spotlight because uh the
head of the other division of marvel
separate from kevin feige this guy named
ike pearl mother not the best human
being in the world but he kind of issued
this weird edict that said
we will not do any more x-men or even
any fantastic four comics we're just
gonna focus on inhumans so that we will
completely own this inhumans uh
storyline and we'll be able to adapt it
into movies and tv shows and we won't
have to do hum we won't have to do
mutant story lines uh because of course
fox owned the mutants in the fantastic
four so this was kind of like at least
commercially from the business side seen
as like a workaround um and look a lot
of fans dug dug uh digged uh enjoyed the
inhuman stuff and uh inhumans came about
on agents of shield and in the abc
series and like i really love the
character of quake in agents of shield
um i think a lot of uh readers uh
especially with kamala khan
kamala khan is an inhuman like elevated
the profile of inhumans and since then
the fact that like marvel studios has
been on the fence of how much they're
gonna fold in agents of shield uh and
and like address it and bring it back in
uh i think a lot of fans of those shows
and of those comics feel like they're
being erased um and i completely
understand why you feel the way i know
why people are yelling at me on twitter
right now and look i understand twitter
is a place for you to vent your
frustrations so vent away be nice uh if
if if you need to use me as a sounding
board i understand um let's just try to
be civil out there seriously but i think
need to be mean i love the character of
black bolt he is one of my favorite
marvel characters i think he's a
fascinating character i love that we saw
him and got strange in the multiverse
madness i was heartbroken when they
killed him to me that was like the most
heartbreaking kill of that movie and but
at least his appearance on the
illuminati tells us the fact they use
anson mount like that i think that is an
indicator that in humans exist
throughout the marvel multiverse and
hopefully they also exist in 616. um
they're making kamala khan a mutant i
think ultimately as a kind of big
picture retcon and restoration and a
simplification because i think
had ike pearl mudder not issued that big
order to not make any new x-men comics
who knows g willow wilson might have
just established that kamala comes in
mutant that seemed to be the case
throughout marvel history they're like
we want to introduce a new character
just make him a mutant but in this case
they were kind of forced into this
awkward place that ended up leading to
this beautiful comic storyline of kamala
khan being an inhuman but i think it
made for like a messier universe for
some people uh at marvel now i think
that messier universe was to their
benefit ultimately and i think this show
would have been better off had they just
called her an inhuman and introduced
terrigen mist i think that would have
been that would have been simpler i
think but i don't mind making her a
mutant because i think that ultimately
opens more doors i don't think that my
favorite parts of kamala khan are the
fact that she's an inhuman um
and i think hopefully this doesn't
cancel out any future in humans i i was
a little worried throughout the series
that the show was pterogenophobic uh but
i'm hearing rumors that daisy ridley as
quake could return in an upcoming mcu
title i want to see black bolts show up
again
and hopefully we can have inhumans and
mutants coexisting uh no one is getting
erased and understand that for every fan
of agents of shield uh every fan of
inhumans who are out there pissed off
right now understand that there were a
lot of uh of x-men fans who were reading
comics uh from like
2010 through 2022 who felt like they
were erased uh i felt like they were
being forgotten uh and i know it's hard
for you to see that because well the
x-men what are you talking about the
x-men got all these movies had some of
the most famous comic runs uh why can't
you share the spotlight i think that
nothing happening right now is saying
that we can't share the spotlight um
uh so i'm hopeful i'm hopeful that we
can get more inhumans because it is an
interesting side of the world you know
you're you're yeah so i love being
humans a lot i'm a huge inhumans fan
like give me maximus the mag give me
lockjaw like i'm all about that give me
reader reader is my favorite inhuman
he's such a cool dude so like i i think
that you know like there is like a bit
of pterogenophobia here in the series
but like we did see that moment where um
uh the contestants turned into that rock
formation like that looked very much
like pterogenesis and i feel like this
is marvel studios way of sort of
they're hiding the inhuman side i feel
it's like all right we're going to show
you the inhuman science and then we're
going to reveal it later on but like
here's a different perspective and like
sort of like how like the pterogenesis
stuff manifests in real life and in
nature rather than being a synthetic
product created by the cree and so like
you know
while they set it up and like they get
people excited for kamala being a mutant
because like they don't really
have faith in the human brand like it's
it's people are really excited about
inhumans in general um like in human
struggle and sales in general so like
they're just like hey if we just make
her a mutant and like get people excited
about that and then like push the
inhuman stuff later um like it sort of
gets people more excited about kamala
khan versus like with as a mutant versus
them in human because like people just
don't aren't really as into humans than
uh the mutants yeah i think that's the
unfortunate reality about the inhumans
throughout the comics is like
i think there's a lot of people right
now who are acting like the inhumans
were like one of the biggest things in
marvel comics ever like my friends if
they were huge deals in the 60s they
would not have
they would have been as big as the x-men
were in the 80s like exactly they were
kind of back-burnered for a reason now
they did get some great stories later on
we have to acknowledge that but like
like a lot of people are acting like
they were there in the 60s reading these
like
like folks like no they were not that
big of a deal and when i said that they
weren't a thing i'm like using the term
it was a thing the way fetch was the
thing like yes people said in humans
decades ago uh but like it wasn't they
didn't have the spotlight they weren't
really getting great storylines until
the modern era um but i think ultimately
i'm saying this as someone who like
would have preferred kamala khan just
being identified as an inhuman on the
show and i think that
uh at the very least like if you want to
call her a mutant great but at least
like say that mention terror genesis at
one point mention intelligent missed
mentioned mist at one point just to like
give us a nod to that
side of the world um but i agree i think
they're afraid calling her an inhuman
and maybe empty maybe we're all in the
bubble right now and there's someone at
marvel studios is like you cannot call
this girl an inhuman there's gonna be a
lot of people just watch the show who
don't understand the comics lore and
they're gonna be like wait she's an
inhuman what are you saying about her
and right you know they're kind of
prematurely worried about that reaction
who knows i don't know like but that
might just be the case and it's
they did use illuminati and multiverse
matters so
that clearly didn't scare them
illuminati as a thing i just think
ultimately it is a little confusing and
i think you don't want your audience to
be confused i would have preferred uh
mutant coming in sooner but i'm not i'm
obviously happy that mutant is now being
spoken out loud now uh because it means
we get uh we get a storm mini series
faster i want an aurora monroe
miniseries
years ago please i'm kind of furious
that we don't have one every time a new
marvel title gets announced i'm like why
is this announcement not for an aurora
12 episode mini series but not a mini
series like eight episodes or eight
seasons in a movie like it joins me not
so we don't already have this uh but
it's and i'm a little thrown that they
chose ms marvel
as a place to introduce mutants i think
just i think they they're setting
themselves up for a lot of confusion
like they could have just established
one of max muffin one division as a
mutant they could have introduced a
mutant in loki uh there's like all kinds
of places like i think in some ways uh
uh
people are gonna yell at me for this but
like you'd have less of a reaction if
you just said like america chavez is a
mutant right like
or like you could have had billy and
tommy coming out of multiverse and
madness one of them just established to
be a mutant you could have had a a
character uh in a hawkeye in what if in
any of these other disney plus titles
you could add a character in moon knight
just call them a mutant at some point
you could have hinted at the existence
of apocalypse any of the times we
visited ancient egypt in the in phase
four and then that would have uh had the
same kind of effect i think that means
exist uh but i i think ultimately it's
fine like i'm
more excited than i am confused uh and i
uh but that's just me uh i guess i wanna
talk about like who do you think the mcu
is gonna identify as a mutant do you
think they're gonna pull this card again
um or do you think after professor x's
candy on multiverse madness do you think
we're gonna get uh the next mutant
sighting is going to be like a famous
new x-men you know who gets introduced
to the mcu um
i i think that
the term mutant is going to be thrown
around as more and more people get
powers in the mcu i think that that's
going to be
like the
the
the grand term for everything it's like
all right you're not human you're a
mutant you're doing weird [ __ ] you're a
mutant so like whenever
regardless of like whether or not
they're inhuman or if they're the
fantastic four i just feel like people
like to just put general labels on
things like that's just how the world
works so it's like all right if you're
either human or you're mutant you're
either human or like you're inhuman like
it's just i think
it's gonna be like that catch-all word
for everyone in the mcu and um
and like that's what's gonna create like
the the rift between humans and mutants
it's like all right you're you're not us
or you're other and so um i think that
you know going forward like a lot of
people might just be labeled as a mutant
like people that aren't typically
mutants in the comics like the like i
said the fantastic four reed richards i
feel like um when they first pop on the
pop-up on the scene people gonna be like
you're a mutant you're weird like you
your genes are mutated it's like oh well
i guess but like
we're not like x-men mutants we're just
regular people but i guess we'll just i
know i don't know we'll just take the
term so i just feel like you know when
with kevin feige when he introduced this
next phase he specifically said mutants
he didn't say x-men he said mutants and
i feel like that was specific and
purposeful because of uh what's going on
in this new phase where like we're
seeing more
people being activated um and turning
into like these energetic type of heroes
so yeah i'm very excited to see what
they're gonna do with all that and how
they handle it but uh yeah it's just i'm
just more excited than anything really i
don't i don't understand why people are
complaining it's fine just get over it
it's it's it's interesting i understand
why people are complaining i i
understand they're they're griping for
sure as soon as i heard bruno say uh a
mutation i'm like uh people are not
gonna like this we speculated that they
could make her a mutant in past episodes
of inside marvel and both you and i were
like i don't think marvel would do that
and that's what they have done so i mean
show's a we know right but i think
that's like uh i think it just gives a
sense of what their priorities are and
like and and which era of the comics
they are sacred to um like i uh yeah uh
but we'll see i mean we're gonna learn
more about what their plans are at comic
con i want to run through a quick a
bunch of quick questions coming out of
this episode first off mt statue of
liberty
it's green again
what the hell how does that connect to
spider-man no way home when that is so
interesting i wonder what happened um
yeah i wonder what happened these two
different shows clearly didn't really
care what the other one was working on i
have no explanation for this i am
assuming that it takes place in the same
reality assuming that even after the
multiversal wipe and this memory spell
at the end it was still bronze so
maybe they repainted it green again i
don't know
who knows
who knows all right so uh cameron
joining kareem and the red daggers does
this mean that cameron is a new member
of the red daggers
i think so i think that they're setting
that up for for cameron to be like a
member of the red daggers and to you
know sort of
like find a new family because he has no
family and so like this they're his new
family and so there's there's probably
going to be some type of um
like what do you call it tension between
the two because like you said the red
daggers were fighting the clandestines
for decades which is like a huge
revelation because like how many other
clandestines are there really like it
kind of makes me feel like there's
more and there's other half
like half clandestine half human even
people out there and so just makes me
wonder like if like if neymar is going
to be one if like you know coming like
moving forward like the reason why
people are have these abilities to do
all these amazing things is because like
they're just mating with clandestine so
yeah no i'm i'm really interested to see
if he's going to be a full-on red dagger
but it seems like that that's that's the
case yeah i mean to answer a question
before i think neymar is going to be the
next character introduced as a mutant
because neymar is mutant in the marvel
comics uh and he is literally considered
the first mutant of the marvel world and
i think like uh assuming that he does
show up in black panther what kind of
forever later this year i think they're
going to call him a mutant as well um
because he is in that case i don't think
anyone's going to bat nine because he
totally is right um okay another
question that i had uh is cameron cured
does he have like a nice balance over
his nor power and if so what caused that
cure was it just like a nice heart to
heart with kamala i think it i mean like
you know
um it sounds cliche but like i think it
was the nice heart-to-heart with kamala
because i think that his powers are very
much tied to his emotions because like
we see that um when he gets this power
um najma glows um like
sort of like green and yellowish and i
think that yellow like
gold rather i think that gold is like
the the emotion singularity i think that
when he
um got that like talk like heart with
kamala he he calmed down and so is his
energy went away um so it's in like you
we see like when when they first meet up
with uh camaron in the alley and bruno
and kamala embrace i feel like uh
cameron got a little jealous and so he
started
freaking out in the alley it's like yo
my emotions are getting out of out of
whack so it's sort of i think it's a
very similar situation to
america chavez where like her powers
were activated by fear and emotions and
so i feel like we're going to learn more
and more about
this you know this golden type of energy
and its connection to emotions um
personally but that's just my weird yeah
all right final thoughts mt about this
series how do you feel now that we're
done with uh miss marvel i'm gonna miss
kamala's dad a lot and kamala's mom and
her whole family like i love
that whole dynamic i thought this show
was like such a nice comfort show
and like it gave me like the it
scratched the the no way home it's that
whole homecoming trilogy like that whole
vibe like i missed that so like if that
scratched that edge for me and like i
just thought it was it's really fun to
like um explore and learn about like
your partition and like pakistani
culture and like i i want more shows
like this where like we're learning we
learn as we like have fun like moon
night i learned a lot about d.i.d
and like you know it's just like it's i
and about egyptian culture like i just
want more of this like show the world of
the mcu like for real like i love it
what do you think how do you feel i
think the show stuck the landing
emotionally and cathartically like i
love this series overall like
the world of uh of kamala khan her as a
character her her family her community
the the production design the use of
color on this show it was such a like
every frame just seems super vibrant and
just
fun to live in every week i look forward
to these episodes every week
it was just like great vibes like the
use of music like it was such a great
jam of a show like yo that last episode
had some bops bro
yeah and it was absolutely wholesome now
i will say there was a bit of a logical
disconnect for me in many parts of the
show and i think that's fine that's to
be expected like a lot of these shows
like you know episode by episode i am
kind of like probably obsessing about
the logic and reading into things a bit
too much and like saying well how does
this character know how to do that well
how does they know how to do that i
think it's our job really the yeah the
feeling you want is the feeling as
you're watching it if you're suspended
in enjoyment as you're watching it
that's all we can really expect from
these shows um i think that uh the the
biggest shortcoming of this series
is just
how um
how ambitious it tries to get with the
with the mcu world building logic while
uh trying to if they're gonna make a
miss marvel show and then uh change the
fact that she's an inhuman i think you
have to make sure you're taking care of
the logic so that no one has any
questions by the end of it and had they
just established that it came from
uh nor magic from another dimension that
was tied in with the the partition
history great fine then in that case we
don't need the bangle and we don't need
the fact that she's a mutant i think
those when you add those things on top
of it that's when we start to get
confusing uh start to get confused um
like if you want to say she's not an
inhuman i don't think anyone's going to
object that much some people might but i
think you just need to clarify that it's
just this then not this plus this plus
this right and uh i think that's where
we got a little lost i think as a big
time travel nerd uh in episode five the
fact they did the pre-destin loop i
would have loved just a bit more time
spent on this show being more of a story
about destiny right i think the only way
you can pull off those feelings super
cathartic and satisfying is the whole
story has to be one about destiny uh and
i don't know if ms marvel is a story
about destiny i think that's maybe like
number eight or number nine of what the
themes of this show are i think the show
is much more a story about identity and
the relationship between the self to the
community
and uh and the importance of family
values and do you have to choose between
your family values and your own personal
interests uh and kamala khan by the end
uh was able to fuse the two was it able
to find a path that her family and and
you know what's great about the show is
the answers were there for kamala right
at the beginning her her parents are
huge avengers nerds the fact that moniva
spent all this time making two whole
costumes and her dad put paint on
face for kamala in that moment because i
and our his
think we all knew instinctively kamala
the answers are right there right your
family is the answer just find a way to
geek out with your family and that's why
i think it was so beautiful that the
family already knew at the end um
so for me as someone who uh who had
honestly buried a lot of my high school
experience and had forgotten a lot of
what it meant to be a kid the show was
just kind of a fun uh reminder of how
well first how anxious uh being a kid
can feel but yeah how fun it can be just
to like goof around with your friends
backstage
in the theater in your high school uh or
to like uh figure out what college
you're going to or how awkward it is to
talk to a guidance counselor and to try
to plan out your whole future um yeah i
think ultimately this series was a lot
of fun and totally really great and i
agree with umt this i want to see more
of this kind of thing in the mcu
i appreciate the big swings that
happened on the show uh i just think the
the marvel studios mechanations of what
exactly kamala khan is just got a little
too overstuffed with explanation and
would have benefited from just a
simplified one and one answer to that
question as opposed to three right like
for sure i agree but we thank everyone
who worked on the show for taking us to
this part of the world
this was a blast covering this show uh
it
like moon night i really love uh one of
these shows that educates me on whether
it is things like a pakistani culture
whether it's things like pakistani
american culture and jersey city
whether it's things like how alternate
dimensions work
as opposed to alternate realms or
universes or with things like loki uh
telling us about like history of things
like pompeii and uh and d.b cooper uh or
things like uh moon knight telling us
about egyptian mythology and d.i.d uh
that's what i love these shows to do is
to help us walk away from the show and i
think my biggest uh the thing i'm most
grateful for is just this amazing um
uh sufi mystic of rumi telling us what
you seek is seeking you something that
blew my mind last week when i finally
was able to just realize what it means
and i think it's to me it's up there
with what is uh grief if not love
persevering
but the fact that they quoted uh a poet
from hundreds of years ago and we're
able to make that matter now i think is
uh brilliant it was truly brilliant
i loved it
and mt i loved diving in this episode
with you every week uh this was a
highlight of every wednesday morning
just being able to connect with you and
uh and theorize take some big thematic
some big theory swings with you uh and
just roll with it when our theories were
disproven or when we were confused uh i
loved being able to unpack this with you
every week same year man i love doing
inside marvel with you every time we get
a new show every time you get a new
thing i just love talking about with you
man he's smart smart dude you are a
smart man as well every time you you say
some theory that's just like you know
what i didn't think about that at all
but it makes a lot of sense it makes a
lot of sense
sorry but before we go i just want to
applaud amman vilani this is like a
first roll right their first role in
like in a major thing so like this
sounds amazing so like great job the mom
finale
you crushed it and we i cannot wait i
believe i'm going to be doing an
interview with him on we're going to try
to work out the timing of it
we're going to try to we're going to try
to schedule it we're going to get it on
the schedule because i have so many
questions for her
and i love how much of a marvel nerd she
really is we're not going to do the
simple press
stuff where we just kind of talked about
so what's it like to be on a marvel set
no i don't care about that i want to
hear her her take on why 616 is not 616.
i want to go and dive into the deep end
so um
[Laughter]
i'm just saying iman if you don't want
to act in marvel superhero movies if you
just want to be a new rockstars host the
invitation is open come on you can just
be here you can work with us
anyway uh well uh thank you all for
joining us don't forget to check out our
merch options at new rockstarsmerch.com
uh follow mt mastertainment lots of
great thoughts happening on empty
twitter feed it's always a delight uh
and you can follow me at eavos uh
subscribe to inside marvel wherever your
podcast follow us on youtube thank you
so much for watching bye everybody
you